sorry I wasn't trying to [__] on Guess
that Tick Tock sound it just said it was
like a funny
it's a funny thing to hear out of your
face why you want to play Guess That
Tick-Tock sound it's a fun segment
we listen to the sound yeah and we but
we don't watch The Tick Tock and then we
try to guess what it's from got it three
two cream pie
that's on Tick Tock now yeah damn
oh that's the dude beating his meat in a
garbage truck yeah
uh porn
yes oh my God yes
one more there's always one left
oh that's the one where he's um popping
her cyst in the Walmart parking lot
gross popping her Nexus in the Walmart
parking lot that's the one right
that's funny because that also probably
it might be like that [__] is on Tick
Tock yeah
now I just imagine he's like killing
some type of bug or some [__] what's uh
what's the answer
holy [__] yeah you got it I mean that
sounded like killing of what is it a
spider a frog oh they're bees Hornet
Hornet's Nest yeah so are they flying
into like genuinely that's what I was
thinking like a hornet's nest so there's
a trend where people get a cup of
gasoline and put it under yeah and they
just fall in and die oh no
it's a cat
you know that one that's a cat I mean I
just know just based on that's a cat
probably uh given water boarding itself
in milk
stupid ass
damn you've nailed that
It's gotta be a cat right
is this dude just like getting head in a
Jacuzzi or something
I mean it's definitely in a pool
some something going on in a pool that'd
be my guess that's me
what the [__]
that's not funny dude
to switch it off bro switch it off
wow
this episode is over
we're done here
oh
that's not funny guys
that's not funny to take to take me in a
vulnerable position like that
dude that bathtub was sucking you off
that would be I don't want to see it
dude
that sound you made
stop dude I don't want to hear it
anymore
how did I not recognize my own voice
foreign
damn you're taking it from that bathtub
for the first time have you tried one of
those
okay it's harder than you would a cold
plunge yeah I'm afraid my dick will not
come back out
mine still hasn't that's what that's
what it was that's what I was saying
yeah I was like okay okay where is it
where is it
feeling around for it hey hey we're
gonna go
damn that's [__] embarrassing so
thanks
for a shame thank you oh yeah if you're
listening um that sound bite well we
played again no it was Cody getting into
a
you were taking that [__] dude oh my
goodness
all right play the next one
it's me again
[Music]
it's me on the treadmill
is this
has to be a slingshot right roller
coaster or something like that
wait don't get too close
she lost control of something in a lake
yeah well sounds like something got away
from her yeah
[Music]
you know what dude I was gonna say
something going down the hill because of
those yeah this should have been obvious
I've done one of these before they're so
fun
oh my God
what is that thing
[Music]
what is that
a marmot
oh it wasn't that cool
it's not that cold animal didn't even
get hurt yeah she's sitting there that's
what I'm saying she's saying like what
do I do um accelerating yeah uh this
smear it yeah that's pretty
straightforward yeah if it was this it
was us in that thing we'd be leaving a
red Trail
[Music]
if you lose
I thought it was me again too I was like
this is not funny anymore guys
I think it's me with a tick tock like
over top of it
all right that seems like a mouthful of
Island Boys yeah yeah
what are their names uh London boy
Sheamus and
the Ireland boys or which one you said
Island Boys okay Irish yeah you're
thinking the Irish boys yeah Ireland
boys famous and Shameless since Shane
what that's Sheamus sir and shame yeah
oh for [__] sake uh I don't know what
that was I think it's someone drinking a
boba tea yeah that's what I was saying I
was saying like mouthful of marshmallows
or something because it sounds like yeah
yeah yeah okay
oh okay
so we were right mouthful of something
[Music]
you got [__] dogs I thought you get
hit if you lose man someone wearing
those glasses in 2023 as well yeah you
know what we should get is smelling
salts
did you see the clips from that other
podcast the British one they're so funny
so funny when people just like yeah I
saw this like these two British guys on
a on a podcast did it and then like all
their producers and [__] did it too like
in one app for like you know in one clip
or whatever it's so funny dude right
like this
so good
yeah Rhino definitely do it
I kind of feel bad about not doing the
Hot Chip though
we still have one but if we all do it
together you do it for her
what or she should do it
what do you think
for sure well Ariana thank you so much
for being here